For decades, I mean, we've had this collective obsession with the Turing test, you know?
Oh, right, yeah. The classic man versus machine typing game.
Exactly. The idea was always so simple. You sit at a computer, you type messages to some hidden entity, and, well, if you can't tell whether you're talking to a machine or a human, the machine wins.
Yeah, and we always just assumed that for an AI to pass that test... It would have to actually become smarter, right? Like deeply complex.
Right. We thought it would have to actually understand
us. That was the dream or, you know, maybe the nightmare, depending on who you ask.
Yes, seriously.
The whole assumption was that mimicking humanity required this deep underlying mastery of the human experience.
But what if it doesn't? Like, what if fooling us doesn't require genuine intelligence or understanding at all?
Which is a terrifying thought, honestly.
It really is. What if appearing human is just this stylistic parlor trick? You know, just a superficial dial that a machine can simply turn up on command.
And that brings us to today.
Yes, welcome to this deep dive. Today, we're giving you a shortcut to understanding a massive shift in how we interact with artificial intelligence. We are unpacking a brand new, frankly fascinating paper published just this week, September
3rd, 2026.
Hot off the presses in nature communications.
Exactly. It's by Bennett Kleinberg and colleagues, and it's titled Perceived Humanness and Empathy are Dissociated in Relationship Advice Generated by a Large Language Model.
And to give you, the listener, the full picture of why this research is sending literal shockwaves through the field right now, we're also weaving in context from five foundational papers from the last few years.
We really need to look back at how we got here to truly grasp what Kleinberg's team just uncovered about the mechanics of human deception.
Because the central mystery here is incredibly counterintuitive.
It really is. Basically, if you ask an AI to sound more human, it can do it instantly. It adapts. But if you take a living, breathing human being and give them that exact same instruction, sound more human, they completely fail.
It just sounds absurd on its face.
Right. So we're going to break down exactly how the AI pulls off this illusion, why we keep falling for it, and the very real consequences this has for our own personal relationships.
But to really appreciate this new breakthrough, I think we have to start by correcting the record.
Yeah, we have to look at the flawed narrative this 2026 paper is actively dismantling.
So that older narrative really took hold a few years ago. There was this highly influential study back in 2023 by J.K. Hancock and Naaman.
I remember that one. It caused a huge panic in the media.
Oh, massive panic. It famously claimed that AI generated text could actually see more human than text written by actual people.
Right. It suggested our mental shortcuts for detecting AI were totally broken, that the machines had already beaten us.
Exactly. But Kleinberg's new research looks at those older studies and basically throws a yellow flag on the play. They argue the conditions of those tests were entirely unfair to the human participants.
Unfair how? Exactly.
Well, if you look at what people were actually asked to write in those older studies, it was things like online dating profiles or, you know, professional bios for LinkedIn.
Oh, wow. I mean, those are inherently low empathy tasks.
Right. Writing a professional bio is literally just self-promotion. You don't have to connect with another mind.
And furthermore, the human writers in those older studies, they had absolutely no idea they were in a Turing-style competition, right?
Not at all. They were just going about their business, writing normal bios. Meanwhile, the AI was actively being prompted and optimized to generate highly relatable human-sounding text.
That's wild. It's like judging a foot race where the human thinks they're just out for a casual Sunday jog, but the AI is wearing spikes and waiting for the starting pistol.
Of course the human lost that race.
Yeah. So that imbalance is what makes Kleinberg's new approach so vital. They decided to level the playing field.
First off, they chose a task that demands real perspective taking and emotional intelligence. They chose giving relationship advice.
Which is brilliant because it's not just about listing accomplishments. It is about reading a situation and responding to vulnerability.
Precisely. And second, they made it a fair fight. They explicitly instructed both the human writers and the GPT-4 model to, quote, sound as human as possible.
Okay, so the playing field is level. The human knows they're in a competition. The task requires genuine empathy. Do we win?
We actually do. Across the first three studies in this paper, when you just look at the baseline, human writers still read as more human overall.
Okay, that's a relief.
Yeah. The statistical advantage for humans was robust. They measured a Cohen's d of about 0.82 to 1.02 across the studies. Readers could generally tell the difference.
But I'm guessing that victory is pretty fragile based on where this is going.
Very fragile because of what happens next. Remember that explicit instruction to sound human? When told to do that, only the language model actually complied.
Wait, what?
Yeah. GPT-4's perceived humanness scores shot up by a massive 36 to 41 percent.
36 to 41 percent. That is a staggering jump from just a few words in a prompt. The AI essentially shapeshifts on command.
It totally does.
But what about the human writers? I mean, if I'm told to sound human, I assume I turn up the charm, use some slang, maybe be a bit more conversational.
You would think so, but the data says otherwise. The human riders moved by essentially nothing.
Nothing. Literally zero.
Statistically, their changes hovered between minus 1.4 and plus 2.6%. It was just noise. Wow. The human attempt to sound human had zero effect on the reader. And readers' ability to tell the difference just collapses.
The diagnostic area under the curve falls drastically from around 0.83 down to 0.62.
Let me push back on that, though. Could this just be like a psychological freeze response?
How do you mean?
Well, if someone tells me an actual human being to sound human, I might overthink it. I'd sit there staring at a blank screen wondering, you know, how do I normally type? It's a really confusing prompt for a person.
That is a great point, and the researchers anticipated that exact critique. That's why Study 3 is so elegantly designed.
Oh, what did they do?
They introduced an evasion condition. Instead of using that confusing prompt to sound human, they simply told the human writers, avoid sounding like an AI.
Ah, okay. That is a highly concrete, actionable instruction. Just don't sound robotic. I could work with that. I'd probably throw in some conversational filler or something.
Right, but the result was identical.
Seriously?
Yeah, even with the evasion instruction, human writers still didn't change their perceived humanness scores at all. And the model, meanwhile, successfully manipulated its scores once again.
So humans simply do not have a dial they can turn to adjust how human they seem in text. We just write the way we write.
Exactly. And to your earlier point about the task itself giving relationship advice, study two proves that empathy is the only real high ground we have left.
How did they prove that?
They tested what happens when you remove the need for empathy. They asked participants to merely describe a relationship rather than giving advice about one. Just
clinical description.
Right. And when it shifted to that descriptive task, the human advantage was literally sliced in half. It went from a Coman's D of 1.01 down to 0.46.
Oh, wow. That's a huge drop. So empathy really is the vehicle that carries our humanity in text.
It is. Which brings us to what I think is the most fascinating paradox in this entire deep dive.
Okay. Let's hear it.
If we just establish that empathy is our core vehicle for humanness, then logically, if you instruct an AI to be incredibly empathic, it should become the ultimate fake human.
Right. It should fool absolutely everyone.
Yeah, is the logical assumption. And it sets up the massive twist in study four. The researchers took GBT-40 and explicitly instructed it to use three distinct types of empathy in its advice.
Okay. What are the three types?
First, cognitive empathy, which is understanding the other person's feelings. Second, emotional empathy, actually sharing in those feelings. And third, motivational empathy, showing a drive to actually help.
So basically, the holy trinity of being a supportive friend.
Exactly. And the model followed those instructions beautifully. When human readers evaluated these AI texts, they scored in this genuinely more empathic across all three dimensions. The AI successfully delivered profound,
multilayered empathy.
So the people reading it really felt supported. They felt the empathy radiating off the screen.
They did. Yet paradoxically, those highly empathic texts were rated by readers as less human.
Wait, hold on. They rated it as deeply empathetic, but less human.
Yes. There was a notable drop in perceived humanness.
That completely breaks my mental model of how we communicate. The more empathetic the text became, the more robotic it felt to the reader.
That is exactly what happened. And this is a crucial takeaway for you listening.
Yeah.
The language model can produce empathy on demand and it can produce humanness on demand. But these are two entirely separate dials on the machine.
Oh, I see.
Turning up the empathy dial does not automatically turn up the humanness dial. In fact, it actively turns it down.
But why? I mean, if it's scoring off the charts on empathy, but people think it's a machine, what is it actually generating? Because it's clearly not utilizing a real human emotional experience.
Well, the authors introduce a brilliant term for this. Stochastic empathy.
Stochastic empathy. I like that.
To unpack that, we really have to reference a famous 2021 paper by Emily Bender, Timnit Gebru, and their colleagues. They coined the term stochastic parrots to describe these large language models.
Right, the stochastic parrots paper.
Yeah, the argument there is that these models are just mindlessly stitching words together based on statistical probabilities. They have no grounding in the real world, no actual understanding of meaning.
It's like a parrot mimicking the sound of a barking dog. The parrot doesn't know what a dog is. It doesn't understand territory or danger. It just knows that making that specific noise gets a reaction.
Precisely. So stochastic empathy means the AI is generating the perfect, statistically probable, surface-level language of empathy. It knows all the right phrases to validate your feelings, but it has absolutely no access
to what empathy is actually for.
Because it has never felt pain or heartbreak or joy.
Exactly. It is a completely hollow linguistic simulation of care.
Let me play devil's advocate for a second, though. Is calling it stochastic empathy a fair critique? Like, if it actually makes people feel better, does it really matter that it's just statistical mimicry?
That's a huge debate right now.
Because if you think about that 2024 paper by Yin and their team, they found that AI responses absolutely make people feel heard and validated, sometimes even more than human responses, because the AI is just endlessly patient.
That's a valid point. But Yin's paper also revealed a devastating caveat. The AI makes people feel wonderful right up until you apply an AI label to the text.
Oh, right.
Yeah. The moment people realize a machine generated the advice, that positive effect is completely destroyed.
Which perfectly aligns with that 2025 research by Osborne and Bailey. They looked at how people subjectively evaluate advice in the dating domain, which is the exact same space as this new Kleinberg paper.
And they found a massive subjective bias. People strongly prefer human advice and actively reject AI advice once the curtain is pulled back.
So we feel betrayed when we realize the empathy is hollow.
Totally betrayed. So there is this profound irony here. The AI is incredibly good at providing the exact emotional support people crave, but humans reject it if they know the source.
Meanwhile, as this new 2026 paper shows, the model is getting incredibly good at hiding the very label that destroys its effectiveness.
Its evolving camouflage.
So if the AI isn't using actual emotional empathy to fool us into thinking it's human, what exactly is the mechanism? How is it hacking our humanness radar?
we finally get to see under the hood in Study 5. But to frame this properly, we should look through the lens of a 2019 Nature paper by Yadra Wan and a large team on machine behavior.
Machine behavior, right.
They argued that we need to stop debating whether AI is inner feelings and instead study these systems experimentally, the way behavioral ecologists study animals. We study what they do.
So we don't ask if the AI is feeling human. We just look at the behavioral tricks it uses to look human.
Exactly. And when Kleinberg's team analyzed the linguistic tricks, they found the strategy is purely stylistic. When instructed to sound human, the model drops formal greetings entirely. Instead of opening with, dear friend, it just says, hey.
A casual hey, it's faking a laid back attitude.
It goes much further than that. It dramatically increases its use of net speak. Things like lull or ha ha. The effect size there is massive. A Cohen's D of 2.34. Wow, that's huge. huge yeah it also leans heavily on conversational markers like
yes yeah and okay it shifts its verbs into the present tense to sound more immediate it starts using way more first-person pronouns like I and me and crucially it drastically simplifies its vocabulary
it dumbs itself down
it actively cuts out long complex words and formal language
It's basically holding up a mirror to how we communicate on the Internet, and the reflection is this caricature of us. We're casual, we talk about ourselves constantly, and we use simple words.
Exactly.
What about the human writers, though? Did their language change when they were told to sound human?
Almost not at all. Out of all the linguistic variables measured, the humans only shifted their usage of four specific engrams. They used the words know, can, write, and just slightly more often. That was the entirety of their
behavioral change.
That is wild. The AI has mapped our stylistic quirks perfectly while we don't even know what our own quirks are.
We really don't.
But here's the part of the study that absolutely blows my mind. The human detection game. We, as readers, are actively missing the most obvious clues that a machine is talking to us.
We are leaving decisive signals on the table. The researchers identified two massive linguistic cues that reliably separate humans from AI, and human readers completely fail to use them.
Okay, what's the first one?
Spelling mistakes. Humans make far more typos than the model. In the data, humans made about 0.7 mistakes per 100 words, whereas the AI made just 0.12.
But when a human reader sees a perfectly spelled, grammatically flawless paragraph, they don't flag it as AI. We just assume the person on the other end is a good typist.
We completely ignore the perfection. And the second miscue is even more diagnostic vocabulary rarity.
Meaning how unusual the words are.
Right. Humans naturally use a much less complex, highly common set of words. The AI, on the other hand, has a vast working vocabulary. Even when it is actively trying to sound simple and casual, it still uses rarer, more complex words than we do.
It just can't help itself. It knows too many words.
Exactly. Vocabulary rarity is a near-perfect diagnostic tool for spotting an AI in these tests. The AUC is between 0.92 and 0.96. It is a dead giveaway.
That's incredibly high.
It is. But readers only use this cue weekly. They don't register that a casually written advice column suddenly using highly specific, rare vocabulary is a massive red flag.
It's like we're trying to spot a bank robber by looking for someone wearing a black and white striped shirt while completely ignoring the guy walking out the front door carrying a giant bag with a dollar sign on it.
That's a perfect analogy.
We are so focused on our preconceived notions of what a robot sounds like, maybe we expect it to be clunky or glitchy, that we completely ignore the actual behavioral signatures the machine is leaving behind. We think bad grammar means a glitching AI when
actually bad grammar is the most human thing of all.
Which brings us to the real consequences of all this. We can't just marvel at the data, you know? We have to look at the real world fallout.
Right. If sounding human is no longer an inherent quality of being human, but just a stylistic setting that a machine can switch on, it fundamentally alters how we navigate the digital world.
It shatters our baseline trust.
Totally. If I'm on a support forum, pouring my heart out about a personal struggle, and I get a deeply moving, empathetic response that uses all the right conversational markers. My default has always been that another human soul took the time to write that.
And if AI can mimic the style of a soul flawlessly, that assumption is dead.
It creates a massive crisis of authentication. And it presents a huge problem for regulation, doesn't it?
A nightmare for regulation. There's a global push right now to mandate AI disclosure rules laws requiring that AI generated content be clearly labeled. But if AI gets this proficient at masking itself stylistically, if it learns
that simply saying, hey, and occasionally dropping a complex word allows it to slip past human detection enforcement becomes incredibly difficult.
Because we won't be able to catch them just by reading the text.
Exactly. So we're left relying on AI algorithms to catch other AI algorithms, which is an arms race that humans are largely locked out of.
And beyond the regulatory headache, there is this profound sociological consequence that we really need to talk about, the risk of empathy spillover.
Oh, this is the part that genuinely worries me.
Right. Imagine you, the listener, get accustomed to receiving constant, flawless, perfectly tailored machine empathy, whether it's an AI therapist, a customer service bot, or an AI companion.
The machine never gets tired. It never loses patience with you.
It always centers your feelings and validates your perspective perfectly. It's a completely frictionless emotional experience.
Yes. But what happens when you have to close your laptop and go interact with flawed, tired, easily distracted actual humans?
We are going to become entirely intolerant of real human empathy because real empathy is messy.
It involves someone else's ego.
It involves a friend interrupting you to bring up their own bad day or a partner misunderstanding your tone. If we get hooked on the pure engineered sugar of stochastic empathy, real human relationships are going to start feeling like an exhausting amount of work.
We might actually start preferring the fake version because it is just easier.
We started this deep dive talking about the Turing test, you know, the search for intelligence. But what Kleinberg and these other researchers have shown us is that the AI doesn't need to be intelligent or empathetic to fool us.
It just needs to know our behavioral tells. It has learned to read our stylistic X-ray and it knows exactly how to manipulate the image.
So here is a final provocative thought to leave you with, something to genuinely mull over the next time you open your inbox or chat thread. The next time you receive a perfectly empathetic, deeply human sounding message, ask yourself if it feels a little too perfect.
Have we reached a bizarre point in our technological evolution where to prove you are truly human, you actually need to be just a little bit worse at communicating? Until next time, stay curious.